yeah well I was also really interested
at the time man now in in the biological
basis of behavior right and so and and
in the and in the relationship between
fundamental motivational systems and
thought because obviously our thought is
grounded in fundamental motivational
systems and your work on disgust which
maybe you can tell the viewers a little
bit about was really interesting to me
because it was an emotional system that
hadn't been studied much I mean you were
really one of the pioneers in the in a
psychological study of disgust well the
way to explain it is that Paul Rozan my
adviser at Penn is the pioneer in the
study of disgust and he'd studied it as
a food-related emotion he'd written a
bit about it being immoral emotion and I
was a graduate student at Penn and I was
interested in morality and I was reading
the Bible and I was reading
anthropological accounts of different
countries and different cultures and at
the time morality was all about
reasoning about harm rights and justice
so Lawrence Kohlberg was the leading
figure in the field and because I was
looking at morality across cultures and
when you look across cultures it's not
just about fairness and Harmon rights
it's about menstruation and food taboos
and skin lesions and it's very physical
and I was you know why why does so many
societies get why is it like the normal
default way of geeing is to somehow
bring the body into morality why is that
and so I just happened to be at Penn
where the world's expert in disgust was
I went to talk to him and that started
one of the best collaborations of my
life and what it led to is is a
broadening of the of the moral domain
basically there's a sort of Western
secular approach that you see in Western
philosophers either morality is about
harm and utilitarianism it's minimize
harm or it's about rights and principles
you know Manuel Conte and a much better
way psychologically I think about
morality is virtue ethics it's just a
lot of stuff it's just we have just a
lot of stuff that we judge on and this
led me eventually to realize that people
on the left and people on the right care
about different stuff everybody cares
about harm and fairness but this stuff
about keeping you know boundaries around
the group build a wall
protect the group hold the group
together hate traitors you know
everybody can do that
but right-wing morality builds on these
additional additional foundations of
these additional emotions and
foundations so that work on disgust that
I was just beginning to talk about them
when we first met in 1994 led eventually
to what we now call moral foundations
theory and with might with about five or
six colleagues if you go to your morals
dot org you can take our tests you can
learn all about it but it led to the
perspective that ultimately was I think
the right perspective as the cultural
war was heating up and as left and right
we're essentially becoming like
different countries different cultures